the wrestler sloane had a deal paramount
it was called pay and play so they had
to pay him by a certain date whether he
did a movie or not so they wanted to
give him beverly hills cop so he reads
beverly's copy says good script but i
got to rewrite it
so he rewrote it and the budget just
doubled and said we can't spend the
money so we met with the heads of
paramount and
they said what would you guys do i said
we'd give it to eddie murphy you wanted
to give daddy murphy
[Music]
top gun
anybody tells you they just made a hit
movie before it goes comes out they have
no clue
the audience is always smarter than any
of us but the movie was something i saw
this photograph and it was this fighter
pilot in this plane and i said this is
star wars on earth this is fantastic i
threw it on don's desk and don said we
gotta option this we got to do this
so we optioned the article we hired two
really hot writers to write it and they
wrote a terrific draft of it and we gave
it to paramount and paramount said we
don't want to make this because aviation
shows just aren't working there was a tv
show about the air force and
they cancelled it
it was done
but
the passion that we had to make the
movie kind of live with us
and fortunately for us that management
in paramount left
and a new management came in it was ned
tanner who used to be ahead of universal
came in to fairmont to run the show and
he came to us and said
i don't know there's nothing here to
make what do you guys have and so we
have this movie top gun and it's tony
scott and we want to use rich we want to
use tom cruise we had a meeting up at
ed's house tony flew in from london he
was dead tired ned turns to tony and
says
tell me the story and tony was just
wiped out he couldn't say a word don
who's a great salesman a great pitch
artist just tells the story of top gun
to ned
and ned's got his dog there and tony's
petting the dog and ned pulls us aside
he said look i'm relying on you two guys
this guy just pets his dog i mean i
don't know what what what's gonna happen
here but you better deliver me a good
movie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fortunately for us we had tom cruise
in the movie we had tony was a brilliant
director and the combination of
the terrific screenwriters we had
working on it we came up with something
that was very unique and
different from what you've seen before
and it was the impetus of tom who
demands excellent even at that young age
he was 121 22 years old at the time
and he just forces you to be the best
you can
he's on everything even at that young
age he was all over this movie and
and tony and tony has he's a brilliant
visualist and he created that look that
we again use in the new top gun
yeah top gun maverick it was all created
by tony and joe kaczynski said i love
tony's work i got to try to give the
audience what tony gave the audience
but we we took it to another level
because of the technology so what we
couldn't do in the first movie we tried
but we couldn't do it was to put a
camera in
the cockpit of an f-14 at the time and
and
get our actors to actually act so we put
them up there and every one of them
threw up and their eyes were rolling
back in their head they always saw that
their heads were down like this we
couldn't use any of the footage except
we got some footage on tom so when tom
wanted to do another one and and joe was
going to direct it he said we got to get
this for real we got to figure out how
to do this and joe
designed cameras we had special cameras
made for the cockpit they were small
enough to get into the cockpit he put
six of them in the cockpit every
possible angle close-up wide angle
behind them in front of him then he had
cameras on the ground he had cameras on
other planes he had helicopters with
cameras so he was photographing it
ways we couldn't do in the original one
and it took 15 months to do this 15
months that we had to deal with the
lawyers from the navy because one of
those cameras came loose the reliability
actor could get hurt
all this stuff was going on
but they figured out a way to do tom
being a phenomenal pilot you can fly and
you can buy helicopters you can find jet
city or whatever it is you can fly he
said we can't allow this to happen again
with our actors we have to figure out a
way
to make sure that they are competent to
get up in an f-18
so he designed a program that took three
months
they were trained in four different
aircraft before they got into that big
jet the f-18
so they were able to withhandle the
g-force also they had to go through
underwater survival that means they put
them in a fuselage a cockpit and they
drop them in the water and they roll
them and they have to figure out how to
get out of that cockpit
and get to the surface now every one of
our actors went through it tom did it
back in 85
and he really didn't have to do it again
but he wanted to show the actors that he
could do it and they should be able to
follow and all of them did it every
actor that was interviewed for that
movie had to realize that that was going
to happen to them they're going to have
to get up and take seven times their
body weight
they hit seven g's which is like an
elephant sitting on your chest can you
imagine what the pressure that you're
under you have to be able to act you
have to be able to turn on the cameras
you have to be able to remember where
the sun is because that's very important
they were rehearsed on the ground by joe
we we built like a little small cockpit
so we rehearsed them then he put him up
in the air but they've been trained all
this time so when he has him up in the
air he can't communicate with him he
communicate with him but he can't see
what they're doing
so they come back on the ground they
review the footage and if he didn't get
what he wanted tom looks at it joe looks
at they set him right back up now
you do one sort of you're exhausted
you're soaking wet even the our pilots
were soaking wet so difficult when you
make these maneuvers they were flipping
them they were doing going straight down
they were going straight when you saw
the movie you could see
the different angles the plane was at
so our actors went through all this
stuff and
and made it through it did they throw up
yes did the only one that didn't was
monica monica was was the toughest of
all of them she
she would she killed it but we got the
footage you can see it on the screen you
can see what these actors go through you
can see what a pilot goes through you
have to really tip your hat to to our
aviators and our top gun pilots what
they do every day is extraordinary and
you have to be in tip-top shape so all
our actors had to be in great shape in
order to get in these planes just like
thomas tom is trains himself like an
athlete he is constantly in the gym he
takes care of himself he really lives to
make movies and to make movies as best
as he possibly can
well he's a better producer in oligarchy
he's he's made so many films he's worked
with so many talented directors and
writers and actors that he's learned so
much he's a sponge and we were fortunate
enough to
use that knowledge that he has to make
top gun a better film
just the way he talked to the actors the
way he worked with joe the way he
demanded everybody to be at best of
their game and it's not just about him
being the star of the movie and caring
about his character he cared about
everybody's character cared about the
story made sure we had the best writers
working on it he made sure that
everything was perfect so we can make
the best movie possible and then he
chipped in his knowledge of storytelling
of character look the whole journey
started we've been trying to make a top
gun movie for many years and never came
together
we
had a script we went to joe kuczynski
and joe said i have an idea of what we
should do
and we flew to paris together and we tom
was doing mission impossible and we sat
down with him in between
setups and joe had a lookbook of what
the movie should look like he did a
poster and he showed this to tom and he
pitched the story and tom when he
finished
picked up his phone called the head of
paramount and said i want to make
another top gun
he was in
beverly hills caught it was a fish out
of water story that that simpson had
this idea he was driving through beverly
hills had this beat-up car and an old
car and the cops pulled him over and
gave him a hard time and he said you
know let's
take somebody from another city and
let's put him into into beverly hills
and
kind of create this kind of same feeling
that i had when i was driving through
beverly hills
and so we they'd hired writers they
worked on it for a while and then we
came back and brought in marty brest who
was we've been fired off of war games
but we thought he was an enormous talent
we were told not to hire him we thought
he was a terrific terrific young
filmmaker
and we had a good script marty worked on
the script
and
we'd sent it to eddie murphy and
paramount said no
we want to give it to stallone
sylvester stallone had a deal paramount
it was called pay and play so they had
to pay him by a certain date whether he
did a movie or not so they wanted to
give him beverly scott so he reads
beverly's copy he says good script but i
gotta rewrite it
so he rewrote it and the budget just
doubled and apparently said we can't
spend the money so we met with the heads
of paramount and
they said what would you guys do i said
we'd give it to eddie murphy you wanted
to give daddy murphy and you said we
couldn't do it because you had a
commitment with stallone so we flew to
new jersey previously the script sat
down with eddie and his kitchener and i
don't remember what room we were in his
house in new jersey
and don again tells the story of
beverly hills cop to him which he'd
already looked at and he committed to do
it
please get in the car sir but thomason
what's the charge possession of a
concealed weapon and disturbing the
peace
disturbing the piece i got thrown out of
a window what's the [ __ ] charge we
can push out of a moving car huh jay
walking the reason they were worried
about eddie murphy is because the
conventional wisdom is that an
african-american actor can open up can't
do more than 25 million dollars at the
box office that's what richard pryor did
so eddie was a tv star he'd certainly
done some movies but he never carried a
movie by himself him alone in the film
was a risk this movie was the highest
grossing r-rated movie at the time was
the highest-grossing r-rated movie till
the hangover came out you know how many
years that is and i mean tickets were
three bucks then when he came so you can
imagine how unique
his talent is how good the direction how
good the story was that people loved it
bad boys
yeah i think it was such a good idea we
had such a a talented group that we
wanted to do with and so we did a test
with michael with dana and john
and it was good
but then dana felt uncomfortable he
didn't feel right about doing the movie
for whatever reason
we eventually got it to sony to to
colombia and one of the executives there
was really passionate about it and
wanted to make this movie in the worst
way he convinced his management that we
should
buy the thing from
from
disney and take it over to
to colombia
and
we tried to figure out who we're going
to put in this and i had met with will
smith
and this guy walks in my office he was
just a star on television i think he'd
done one movie and he's big he's funny
and he's a great guy
so i said it's got to be will smith we
got to use will smith and then one of
the executives at sony said
you got to watch martin's show he's so
funny
so we convinced him to go with will and
go with martin they said fine but you
got x amount of dollars to make the
movie which wasn't enough to make our
vision of the movie
but michael fortunately committed to do
it and
he made the movie in fact at one point
he wanted to finish filming a sequence
and they said you have to cut the
cameras and he said i'm going to write
you a check
to finish the day and he wrote him a
check to sony to so he could finish the
day cut two months later was one of
their biggest pictures of the year
i don't know if they ever wrote michael
a check back or if he canceled the check
we have to ask him
csi you know it's always about the
characters and what anthony carroll
did and anne they created these
fantastic characters and then you have
billy peterson who's a brilliant actor
and he he helped create the character
of grissom so that captivated audience
plus we shot it in a different way it
was like an anthony calls it a mini
movie it's
feature television is how he refers to
it so
that
and the look of it was different than
what you normally saw on television i
believe you're going to do something
visual it's not radio you might as well
make it really interesting so we
surrounded that series with
phenomenal technicians everything okay
here yes ma'am
control junks is a code for copy that
are you the new girl
yeah hi i'm holly gribbs thanks
catherine willows and i'm leslie stahl
look forget the formalities which one of
you people is gonna clean my counter
here let me tell you something lady if
you don't care about catching the
suspect neither do we we're out of here
you pick your gun up tomorrow
and danny cannon who directed the pilot
is somebody who i'd followed his career
and saw some movies he'd made and said
this guy's really talented he'd never
done television before so it was a
process of convincing all the executives
at cbs that he had the ability to make
something really special and his
direction the way he designed it the way
he did it work with carol ann and
anthony and billy and the cast they put
together and my television team
all worked on it together plus the great
executives at cbs who really made this
come to life and they took a big chance
because it was it was put on friday
night because they didn't think it was
anybody was going to watch it and that's
kind of a dead night of television
and all of a sudden it started to pick
up an audience and so cvs took this real
chance and said all right let's put it
on thursday night thursday night is the
the the god of television it's where
everybody watches television that's
where the highest rated shows are on
thursday night and they gave me this
call and they said we're going to put on
30 oh my god that's the end of that
series because you're going up against
er at the time i mean all the big series
and they were right now was wrong the
show became a huge success
at one point i think we had
i know five or six shows in the top ten
which was unbelievable it's always about
the writing you got to have great
stories
develop great characters and that's what
has been our success for all these
spin-offs so it was a collaboration of
what they wanted to do but the impetus
is always on our shows it's the director
who comes in who does the pilot and sets
the tone for the series and so you take
that tone and you switch it to
the next one it's csi miami or csi new
york or csi cyber or now with csi all
over again so we kind of put that
imprint that danny created very early on
on the first pilot and try to carry that
through the continuity of that
and
unfortunately
the police will never go out of business
because somebody's always trying to take
somebody from some something from
somebody else so there there's always
unfortunately crime somebody's got to
solve the crimes the the
scientists that are so important now in
solving the crimes they're at the
forefront and the technology is getting
better and better so it's it's easier
for them to kind of zero in on who did
it and it's usually why they did it and
then you find out who did it
but the technology is is phenomenal and
we're
the new series which is coming out which
has already had one season gonna have
another season you're gonna see all
kinds of new technology that the
government and scientists have created
it's about storytelling it's about
characters it's about the actors you
choose it's about the writing it's about
the producing but it always starts with
the characters in the writing
amazing race
well bertrand van muenster who's the one
who brought the series to us
he was a cameraman and producer on cops
so he had this kind of way of filming
people and making things happen you
could drop him anywhere in the world
where people don't speak the language
that you know he will find a film crew
he will find people he will make it
happen
he and his wife are fantastic they came
his wife came up with the idea of it and
they've been traipsing around the world
for i don't know 17 years now making
this this series so i gotta tip my hat
to him for for what he pulled off and
what he
created this fantastic show that people
sit in their homes and they watch us and
it's their travel log you know it was an
idea that was pitched to us early on we
loved it we took it to the network
and we're very fortunate that it
captured
the zeitgeist of the public and it's
it's really about the contestants and
it's about the casting of the
contestants and and the kind of stunts
that they put them through
going through the the series which is
you know 8 10 13 episodes depending on
what but it's always about the
contestant and the fact that it's that
we have great crews around them great
producers that do everything for us and
that's the the magic of that show you
know everybody was vaccinated and
everybody had to wear masks when they
were off camera or around the camera we
had a zones and b zones and
and you just keep going you fight
through it we fight through it on all
our productions fortunately it's it's a
five-day thing that they're gone it's
it's a bad cold it's a that flu there
are therapeutics now that can help you
get through it faster
so we we find things to shoot when
they're down and when they come back
it's business as usual
pirates of the caribbean
well ellie and rossio were writers we
always wanted to work with they'd done
shrek and they have a unique vision and
they had a take on this
to use a lot of the stuff from the ride
and infuse it in into the movie
and that's what propelled me to get
really excited about it it wasn't a a
straight ahead pirate movie there was a
supernatural there were all the things
that you see in the ride the skeletons
all the things that are there and they
put that into the script and i said this
is a movie i'd like to go see
so what now jack sparrow we should be
two immortals locked in an epic battle
until judgment day
or you could surrender the fact that we
could convince court rubinski who i
thought was an enormous talent i saw a
mouse hunt i said he's got a wonderful
sentiment there's a reality about him
again he was only given an outline and
he said yeah this is fun i i'll join the
ride on this one so he was part of
creating the script with ted and terry
what we brought on the screen then the
next element is we got to get an actor
right so johnny depp is somebody i
always admired and wanted to work with
because he's a gifted actor and i flew
to france
and had a bunch of storyboards and
designs of what the ships were going to
look like what the costumes were going
to look like
and presented it to him over a lunch
and he said i love this
you know send me the script let's see if
we can do it
now what johnny brought to it is he
created that character what was on the
page originally the 10 terry wrote was
an interesting pirate more like burt
lancaster
but johnny had been watching cartoons
with his daughter and he loved pepe le
pew and he was friendly with keith
richards and he said you know the way
keith acts i'm going to try to do that
so we kind of mimicked those two things
and put them together and created jack
sparrow
to tie up your boat at the dock
and i shall need to know your name
what is it three shillings
and we forget the name
welcome to port oil now that freaked the
studio out because he was he drunk
what's the story with his carrying his
gold teeth and
he said
please don't worry about this let me cut
some footage together after we were
filming and show it to you so we cut
like 15 minutes of film because some of
the performances were way out there so
we kind of narrowed it down and showed
it to them and they loved what they saw
and and even when we finished the movie
and we'd spent all these months making
this film in the caribbean
everybody's was saying how can you make
a movie about
a theme park ride they were killing us
in the press
until they saw the movie it didn't open
huge it opened up 45 million dollars
which is a nice opening
but then the next weekend and the next
weekend it just kept going and going
going and the second and third ones were
enormous hits
i mean they were one of the top three
successes at the time
when they came over over a billion
dollars
american gigolo
well paul schrader is a is a brilliant
writer and a terrific director and he
always comes up with unique concepts and
characters and
you know raging bull was one of them so
he's he's somebody that is a real deep
thinker and a really smart intellectual
director and writer and he came up with
a story about american jingle it was
originally john travolta who was going
to star in it but john had some problems
with his family and he lost a girlfriend
and he wasn't emotionally committed to
start the movie
but paul felt that
richard gere would be the perfect
american jiggle he'd just come out in mr
goodbar
and paramount had a relationship with
him but they really wanted to replace it
john with a major movie star he wasn't a
major movie star yet he'd done one very
interesting done our moods but the most
interesting was good bar
but
paul
went out to malibu and sat down with
richard and convinced over a weekend he
sat down with richard convinced him to
do the movie paramount wanted
reeves to do the movie because he was
superman and he was a huge star
fortunately over that weekend he passed
we walked in monday morning into
paramount paul had
richard gere in his back pocket he said
richard wants to do it in pyramid
richard gere why richard gere and so
he is very persuasive and convinced him
that richard be the right person to do
it but the budget was very high because
we had travolta in it so they gave me a
number i don't remember what the number
was if you can get the budget down to
this we'll make it with richard and we
did and we had to alter all his clothes
because the clothes was made by armani
for travolta
so we'd flown over to italy with with
travolta and paul and came back and all
this brilliant clothes now we had to
alter it for richard which all worked
out fine he looked fantastic in the
movie paul always had this vision that
america was just wearing
blue jeans
they were all everybody was in blue
jeans nobody wears suit and tie except
for businessmen and
paul said it's going to change we're
going to change it and that's how he
dressed richard he put him in a tie and
a suit and four jackets and he he looked
fantastic
so that became american jewel but it was
a great script
[Music]
armageddon it always comes down to the
movie and if you have a good movie that
audiences will embrace that's the key to
my career in any movie so you have to
make a film that's unique and different
michael bay always has a terrific vision
he's a great director he's somebody that
has a wonderful sense of humor it's
there are very few directors that can do
comedy and do action they do one or the
other and if they do it together
chances are become silly michael stuff
is never silly it's grounded in reality
and just the casting of it bruce willis
to be able to get bruce willis and then
to populate it with
ben and the rest of the cast we put
together but there were so many funny
things in the script
and the fact bruce said to me he said
look i read the script
don't change the ending i have to die in
this please don't promise me jerry then
you won't change the ending i said we
won't change
usually what happens you go to a preview
and they want the key hero to live and
fortunately we
we kept it the way it was and became a
huge success
flash stands don simpson had been a
friend of mine he was a roommate of mine
he
got a job at paramount and rode through
the ranks and became the head of
production i was developing with him
flashdance he gave it to me and said you
could we we need a producer on this this
thing is going we're making this thing
and there's nobody kind of running the
ship so i came in and we brought in
adrian lyon who was a director that i
always admired who has a phenomenal eye
for for talent and and he's got a real
vision cinematography the way he designs
things is unique we always look for
unique visions from directors and he had
that unique vision
and it was so interesting because we
worked on the script really hard we had
a lot of writers work on it don's
mastery of character and story was just
amazing so that was such a great boon to
to that project and then the casting
process came in an adrian
who has a phenomenal eye for women he's
just he can see things that i can't see
and public can't see we were casting and
a young girl walks in and she's got
shaggy hair and she's got off a plane
she was on a in europe touring before
she went to college and he
puts her on camera and i i said adrian
what are you spending so much time with
what are you doing
and he said just wait just wait just
wait so he brings a makeup artist in and
they make her up
and then he she reads some of the scenes
he nailed it he picked jennifer bills
nobody else saw it so we we tested three
women the executives picked one of the
girls not her
then michael eisner was the head of the
studio at the time brought in all the
secretaries and all the assistants and
showed them all three women and they all
picked jennifer biltz and that's how
jennifer beals became
the star of flashdance adrian was really
passionate about her and we supported
adrian but a lot of the executives
didn't see what adrian saw in her but
everybody else did national treasure
disney wanted to make the movie
uh they didn't have a script that they
were happy with so we got involved with
john turtletop and developed something
that they liked a lot
and we had to cast it and i always been
a huge fan of nick and wanted to we'd
already worked with nick i think i think
i did a rock previously with nick and he
is somebody that is so quirky so
interesting you never know what you're
gonna get with nick you know he's that's
he's unpredictable and that's what
audiences love about him the location of
of
hidden items of
historic and
intrinsic
value a treasure map
that's where we lost the fbi
you treasure hunters aren't you
we're more like treasure protectors
so we we got a script we convinced nick
to do it and fortunately john did a
phenomenal job directing it again my
career is built on the backs of talent
writers
talented directors toner actors studio
executives who get it distribution
people people who
advertise and market our stuff you need
an army to get a hit movie it starts
with the with the core of the idea that
the writer comes up with and the
characters that he creates and then you
bring a director involved in the heap
makes it blossom and then you you
populate it with great actors and
sometimes you make magic sometimes you
don't but it does happen sometimes
[Music]